now Princess of Wales this is Kate
showing you what she wants to do with
that title launching a new campaign
called shaping us to make us all wake up
to the importance of those Early
Childhood years
during this time we lay the foundations
and building blocks for life
it is when we learn to understand
ourselves
understand others and understand the
world in which we live
this is why it is essential
to not only understand the unique
importance of our earliest years
but to know what we can all do to help
raise future generations of happy
healthy adults
they're hoping this video brings it to
life showing how from birth to five a
child is shaped by their contact not
just with their parents but others like
teachers or family friends
foreign
[Music]
Ty ambassadors are helping them to
spread it's quite a lot of pressure to
put on parents you know and I think you
know they are our children and we'll
raise them to the best of our ability
but actually they're saying it takes a
village is really true
over a decade Kate's been learning about
how much those early years can impact
things like mental health problems or
addiction as an adult but when families
are struggling enough to pay their
heating or food bills well the campaign
really cut through
I hope so because that is exactly why it
is relevant at the moment because it's
exactly those kind of pressures that are
impacting parents today so this campaign
is about how do we help parents how do
we support them as individuals and as
communities
the media's obsession with how she looks
can at times overshadow what Kate has
got to say but we're told that she sees
this as the start of a vital
conversation with the nation we now wait
to see if people really listen and want
to do something about it
Rihanna Mills Sky News